haiya Dora Shiro comes back this month
yes I'm really pumped about that I'm
bummed out that it's gonna be the last
season but oh I'm so looking forward to
it and there's so much to look forward
to there's gonna be more Scorpia who is
my favorite character in the whole dang
thing all the characters are great we
get to see Beau being neurotic we get to
see what entrapped is gonna get up to
now we get to figure out how the heck
this is all gonna work after the finale
at the end of season 4 which that was
like a complete reset of status quo like
what is gonna happen and there's a
lingering question with one of the
characters involved that being Katra and
the question of are they going to try
and redeem her and if they do how now
this isn't necessarily meant to be
speculative
in terms of what I think will or won't
be in the show I don't know I have no
particular insight and I'm not great at
theorizing plot lines I've done videos
explaining why I suck at that it's just
not how my head works however I think
there are things that can be said about
whether or not that's something that
they should do it all and if they're
going to do it are there better or worse
ways to go about it now I do want to
give some credit here this video was
inspired and sort of spawned out of a
video done by the sin Squad which I will
link in the description it's a great
video you should watch it actually you
should subscribe to that channel anyway
because it's really good so in that
video they were talking about the idea
of redemption in general with a heavy
focus on character but I really want to
zero in on that so Katra has been a
villain since the get-go but on an
escalating scale
because we started out in season one and
she and a door are in the hoard adora
leaves the hoard Katra doesn't leave she
stays in an end feels very bitterly
towards Medora there is an escalation
from there on as we realize it's not
just her spitefulness towards adored
like she is really looking to cause a
door of massive harm and even as Skorpio
comes in and tries to become friends
with her Katra treats her like garbage
she back stabs and trapped she
absolutely gets obliterated for the but
because of a half-second she thinks she
can maybe trust shadow weaver and that
doesn't pay off and eventually by the
end of season 4 she is even she's even
gone against Hordak all in an effort to
be doing as much name as pot she
practically ended the world at the end
of season 3
like that's how far gone she is so given
that we came from an origin point of her
being odorous friend combined with the
fact that this is ultimately a show for
a younger audience will they try to
redeem her basically with the power of
friendship so the first question is
should they be redeeming her at all and
if this wasn't a show for kids
my gut instinct answer that would be no
no she has done too much damage
far too deliberately like knowingly this
isn't a case of she wanted to cause this
much damage but cause this one no she's
known what she was doing she may have
miscalculated thinking that it that what
she was doing would make her happy only
to have it isolate her and make her more
and more and more miserable as time goes
on but as far as her actions and the
consequences on other people she has
been knowingly doing what she has been
doing for most of this time if not the
entirety of it
she is really far gone I'm not sure
it's possible to redeem her but then
there is that nagging thing in the back
of my head it is for kids and also I've
got a bias on this because I watched the
show with my daughter and catch was her
favorite character and she knows
catchers a bad guy
she has no illusions about that but I
think she kind of wants to see catch her
redeemed but the Ridley she doesn't want
to see captured I although she has told
me she thinks that might happen and I
don't I don't know where you go with
that because while it is a lesson with a
certain amount of value to say look some
people don't get better some people if
they can be helped but you've tried
everything that you can think of and
it's not helping you need to stop trying
to save them that's a valuable life
lesson but is it a lesson that should be
taught to the age groups of the same dad
I mean again my daughter is eight is
that a lesson I'm ready for her to learn
is that a lesson that maybe would make
more sense to her I don't know her age I
don't know but it does mean that if
they're going to try and redeem Katra
they have to be very careful about how
they do that here's the worst possible
option I think in terms of inadvertent
negative message I'm gonna underline
that word inadvertent if the show does
that I'm gonna talk about the bad
implications of that but I'm also gonna
say I do not believe that even if this
show does this that it will be their
intent to have these implications if
Katra is redeemed to the point that she
is basically friends with really any of
the people who she stabbed in the back
whether it be Scorpia
adora and trapped uh if she reconnects
firmly like in a way that is meant to be
a happy ending with any or all three of
those
that's the worst option because that
gives the message of somebody was
abusive repeatedly he tried to help you
gave them a chance to change they didn't
you walked away which was the right
thing to do which is what the show was
done especially with Skorpio in the
previous season because when scorpio
walked away from capture that was framed
as the best thing she could have done
under the circumstances all of that
exactly what it should be to then have a
comeback ultimately as but don't give up
altogether maybe they'll still be okay
at some point in the future while I may
have questioned the idea of teaching
younger children you know sometimes you
cannot save people is a harsh lesson to
learn that's better than this because
this would actually be I feel actively
dangerous because the whole idea of well
don't give up they're your friend you
have to keep trying no no sometimes
whether it's friends or family sometimes
somebody is so abusive or so bad for you
or so unwilling or unable to change
their behavior that you need to walk
away and you need to know how to process
that and be okay with that
and not be having one eye out going
waiting for them to get better so that
you can then go back because that's
that's how abusive cycles get going so
that would be the absolute worst case
scenario does that mean I think it's
impossible to redeem Katra
no I think there's two ways that they
could redeem Katra I think if they're
gonna try to redeem her the easier way
and I would find to be
the less interesting way it would work
but it would feel for me a little cheap
but that would be for her to basically
self-sacrifice so the reason that first
thing that I said would be the worst
possible option is because it just sets
her up to completely mess with people
like adora and scorpion and trapped all
over again
so what we can't have is ending with her
in a position where she can hurt these
people in the same way again so what you
can do is you can have redemption
through self-sacrifice that results in
her death you know something happens
with horde Prime and she I don't know if
it would be literally her throwing
herself in front of the bullet in front
of the bullet meant for someone like
adora or Scorpia and taking that instead
but something of being effectively that
that would function as a Redemption
narrative that would not be as harmful I
do think that would be kind of lazy
though because the thing about redeeming
someone that way is it allows them to
have Redemption without having to
actually put in the work involved to
become a better person because they're
dead they don't have to improve they
went out on the moment they did
something better but proper redemption
real redemption in life making up for
your mistakes is an ongoing project
because if your habits in your patterns
involve abuse then you need to live your
life without falling back into those
habits and patterns and that's work
that's long-term work and redemption
that's part of I don't like Redemption
through death because in many ways it
it's the easy way out because you don't
have to face the long-term consequences
of what you did and how much work you're
gonna have to do to fix it instead you
just get redeemed because you're dead
again better than that first
option I don't love it though here's
what I would like to see effectively if
they are going to try and redeem her
because this from my way of thinking
this sort of thing is what would work
and I would be okay with and I don't
think would have the problems of the
other two that I mentioned now again
this is broad strokes I'm talking about
but if they have Katra turn against
horde prime that'll have to be a
component and any direction you go have
her recognize what she's done to people
like adora apologize to adora Skorpio
entrap to everybody not ask for
forgiveness or if she asked to be told I
don't know if you can have that and to
accept that answer and then to leave
with someone other than these other
characters that I've been mentioning to
build a new life somewhere else with a
new person and a clean slate so that
it's not just going to fall back into
the same repeated patterns of abuse who
would this new person be I don't know it
could be you could feasibly be a new
character I don't think someone like
Double Trouble works because double
troubles too much of a sort of a black
hole in terms of morality or whatever
I suppose you know who it could be it
could be Lonnie
it could be Kyle it could be or Haley oh
it could be that trio because yes
abusive towards them but in the manner
of a commanding officer she hasn't
manipulated and twisted the knife into
those three the way that she has with
adora Skorpio entrapped it because the
people who you can hurt the most are the
people you're the closest to and she was
never
that close to Lanikai Lenore helio but
if she ends the show with them you know
basically leaving with them to try and
start some other life understanding that
she has work to do and she needs to try
and change but she's doing it with new
people that she can start from a clean
as clean a place as possible with and
build new patterns because as much as if
you've screwed up you want forgiveness
and you want to go back to the life you
had from before part of getting better
is recognizing that certain
circumstances and being around certain
people is gonna slip you back into
certain habits so she can't be around
adora Skorpio and trapped the rebellion
I because even if they end the show at a
and we're all friends now a moment I
won't be able to bring myself to believe
she'll be able to hold that but if she
goes off with the with that trio with
Loni Kyle and Rahel EO knowing that
someone like Lani
will call catch her out when she starts
slipping someone like Kyle will you know
be encouraging that someone like well
hey Leo will just give the best side I
as needed that situation I could believe
she could leave and go into and maybe
maybe with work she'll get better and
that sort of scenario would be the way
that I think would be the best and
possibly the only way really to properly
redeem Katra that's assuming they try
and redeem her at all because maybe they
won't although that would be a little
dark for a kids show we'll find out a
couple weeks what are your thoughts on
Katra should she be redeemed can she be
redeemed what are your thoughts on what
I floated as do the best way to do it
whatever your thoughts are detailed or
broad-stroke notions like what I've had
drop something down in the comments and
let's talk about it
usual stuff to do like subscribe I've
got a patreon all those wonderful and
helpful things but also you don't have
to do any of it because at the end of
the day you are the council I just want
your meetings and until next time this
council is a jerk
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]